hello guys and welcome to another video
so the release date for the next three
upcoming Star Wars films has been
revealed and it is as follows May 22
2026 December 18 2026 December 17 2027.
now you might have realized that we have
two Star Wars films releasing in the
same year and all up Three Star Wars
films releasing and the span of a year
and a half now to me that is quite crazy
and quite unexpected now in my opinion I
think this is a risky and bold move but
before we discuss the spur but I'm going
to give you my prediction of what I
think these Star Wars films are so I
think the first Star Wars film is going
to be the ray Star Wars film which is
set after episode nine then I think the
second film is going to be Dave filoni's
film which is rumored to be heir to the
Empire and then the third film I reckon
will be dawn of the Jedi now it is
possible one of these could be tanker
matini's film but I reckon we won't be
seeing that film for quite some time if
I'm going to be honest with you guys now
the reason why I think it's a risky and
bold move releasing two installers moves
in the same year as if the first film is
not amazing if it's not super good it's
going to really affect the second film
and I don't think people are going to
rush to see it and if the first film is
going to be the ray one there's a lot of
hate surrounding the sequel so having
the first Star Wars film we haven't had
for many years to be a sequel related
one is also a bold move but in my
opinion them releasing two of these
films in the same year does show that
they're confident in the films that
they're making here but I am still
worried and have my concerns but my
fingers are crossed and I hope for all
these films to be great because if they
are all great we don't have to wait too
long to see these films it's only a year
and a half around that to see all three
of these films which again is very
surprising to have such a small release
window for all of these films but anyway
let me know your guys's thoughts in the
comments section below and if you're new
to the Channel please consider
subscribing thanks for watching guys